i repeat i haven't been this excited
about a discovery since crispr
we found something enigmatic that like
crispr is associated with microbial
genomes
we have named these unique entities
borgs so hello
and welcome to the cheeky science show
where in this video we'll be elucidating
a bit on this fantastic
tweets written by joe banfield
who not only is excellent at tweeting
but it's also a fantastic researcher and
has recently published a pre-print from
her lab
on what you will know at the end of the
video as books
so to steal jill's great publicity
tactics
i have never been so excited to make a
video you definitely will want to watch
until the end
and help me make this video go viral
because you know you're likely one of
the first people still to know about
this fascinating discovery
so the name of this preprint is borg's
are giants extra chromosomal elements
with the potential to augment methane
oxidation
now i don't usually cover preprints on
this channel
so lucky authors and well lucky you
listeners
but i thought i'd make the exception
since i read the paper and thought it
was pretty cool
and wanted to be the first to make a
youtube video on it so let's hope by the
time i finish making the video i salam
anyway in this video we'll cover what
they discovered in this preprint
so basically what are borgs and why this
discovery could be
revolutionary so the story begins with
jill banfield
who was a ga microbiologist at the
university of california berkeley
where her lab has many areas of focus
from looking at cyanobacteria through to
examining the human microbiome however
this story begins with mud
and trying to explore how microbes
influence the carbon cycle
and interconnected with the carbon cycle
is the consumption
and production of methane and so in
particular the lab is interested in
understanding the microbial composition
of
anaerobic soils where there's high
methane production but also consumption
and the way that they examine this is
through a whole community meta genomic
approach
with metagenomics referring to the study
of a collection of genetic material from
a mixed community of organisms
so in this case examining all the
different organisms in a soil sample and
so
with all the advances in the ability of
sequencing
dna and the reduced costs of doing this
this area has greatly expanded over the
last decade or so
and so this has really helped us to
identify new organisms based on dna
sequences
and you can infer a lot about an
organism from its dna sequence
which kind of does make sense when you
realize it is your genetic blueprints
but anyway when they were doing this
they discovered something
very interesting in wetland soils in
california
and these were strange dna elements
otherwise known as extra chromosomal
elements
so they fall under the same umbrella as
mobile genetic elements and plasmids if
you come across those terms
and from this sediment sample and from
another sediments
sample in colorado they were able to
manually curate
the complete sequences of four of these
genetic elements and these strange
elements had some very
interesting and in combination unique
features
that had never been seen before and so
the first notable thing
is the fact that these genetic elements
are really big
in comparison to other previously
identified extra chromosomal elements
moreover they have a linear sequence
with many direct
repeat sequences the sequences also had
a very low gc contents
with gc standing for guanine and
cytosine which are two out of the four
nucleotides that make up dna sequences
and low here refers to in the context of
comparing this sequence
with the sequences of different archaea
that live in the soil
and so our ko are kind of like bacteria
but then definitely not bacterial
um they're single cells organisms those
are very prevalent in harsh conditions
in this case from these wetland samples
very anaerobic so low oxygen conditions
and one of the archaea that's highly
prevalent in these soils
is methanopyridines which is an archaea
that can actually
consume methane and so in comparison to
the dna sequence of
methanol paradigms these newly
identified sequences
have a low gc content and so that
suggests that this is something novel
and not just some additional dna
that's part of methanol paradigms and in
addition
they also identified a lot of protein
coding genes in these extra chromosomal
elements
with a lot of them being metabolism
relevant genes
interestingly a majority of the genes
were also novel
and we'll come on to that maybe a little
bit later but actually around 21
of the predicted proteins from these
genes had close matches to proteins of
archaea
most notably to methanol paradigms
however when they looked at the
relationship between
these genetic elements and coexisting
methanol paradigms
they didn't really see a consistent
relationship
and in fact in some cases the abundance
of these novel genetic elements
were up to eight times more abundance
than methanol paradigms
but it raised the idea that these
protein sequences
must have somehow been acquired from
these alkal bilateral gene transfer
and so with this information and the
fact that the characteristics of these
genetic elements
don't have much overlap with other extra
chromosomal elements such as ferrous
plasmids and mini chromosomes
they concluded that these genomes must
represent novel
archaeal extra chromosomal elements that
occur in association
with but not as part of
methanoparadine's genomes
and now for the notable sentence we
refer to these as borgs
a name that reflects their propensity to
assimilate genes from organisms
most notably methanopyridines
so to elaborate a little the data was
suggestive
of these extra chromosomal elements or
borgs
having the ability to inhabit
my family paradigms and to accumulate
some of their genes
and integrate it into their own genome
and so
there could be some kind of symbiosis
relationship whereby methanol paradigms
by having these bugs
could benefit from them and it also
enables the bugs to survive
and so this is where it gets a bit weird
because like viruses
these bugs are incapable of living as
their own entity
and they have to depend on other
organisms to survive
but based on their dna sequence and the
fact that they have some genes that are
very very similar to genes that are
already found in methanopyridines it
suggested that this is where the genes
initially were derived from
so borgs don't actually stand for
anything in fact the name is a reference
to
the star trek borgs now i can't really
tell you too much about this because
embarrassingly i've not seen star trek
but apparently borgs
in star trek are aliens that assimilate
the biology of other creatures
so like the borgs in that the borgs are
assimilating genes
from the archaea that they're inhabiting
so yeah these are the borgs so probably
because i'll forget to mention it later
i'll mention it now
it's important to point out here that
this relationship with
methanol paradigms and the borgs at the
moment is currently
inferred from the dna relationship and
the fact that they're present in the
same soil sample
but it's very hard to know at the moment
what the actual
physical relationship with them is and
asking actual questions about
how the presence of borgs inside
methanopyridines if that's occurring
how it's having an impact on methanol
paradigms and the reason that that's
quite challenging to do is because
archaea unlike human cell lines that i
grow in
a lab are very hard if not impossible
currently to actually grow
in lab environments and so the metal
genomic approach
is kind of like the gold standard for
being able to identify things
um and so you do have to buy that in
mind or at least remember it at the back
of your head
when we proceed with this video anyway
in this pre-print
they identify 19 different sequences or
books in this case
and each of them has i don't really know
why maybe it's
another star trek thing they all have
different colors and the one that they
focus on
more in this study is of the lilac borg
and i do like the color lie look so i'm
happy for that
and the primary reason they focus on the
lilac borg
is because it seems to co-occur with a
single group of relatively abundant
methanol paradigms
that likely in this case actually
represents the host
and so here they provide quite a
thorough analysis of the different genes
that they could find in these sequences
so of the bulk genes that they could
functionally identify
the authors categorized them into three
key characteristics
the first one being the ability to
expand the redox and respiratory
capacity
of methanol paradigms secondly the
ability to respond to
changing environmental conditions maybe
by manipulating
what proteins are present in the
membrane of these
rkr and then lastly the ability to
augment methanol paradigms ability for
methane oxidation
and in particular it's this latter
function this ability to maybe augment
methane oxidation
which is one of the reasons why this
discovery could be revolutionary
and this is because methane is a
greenhouse gas
in fact it's even more potent than
carbon dioxide
and some of the efforts to try and
mitigate the effects of climate change
one approach is to increase methane
oxidation which is a process that's
carried out by these methanographs
such as methanoparadines
and so if there's some ability of these
bugs to actually augment this process
then that could be potentially be
harnessed to somehow
increase the abundance of bugs or the
genes encoded by these borgs
to improve methane oxidation but as i
mentioned earlier
the majority of these genes encoded by
these bulk elements
are unknown at the moment and that's
actually pretty exciting
i have to say i guess it goes back to
that saying of there's the things you
know
you know and then there's the things
that you know that you don't know and
because we don't know what it is or what
they do is
new biology and that's always quite
exciting it'll be interesting to find
out the potential of these different
proteins
and i suspect that the lab have some
hints or some ideas as to what they
might be doing
but for now there is not any particular
mention
in the preprint however there is a bit
of additional information in some
articles covering this paper
when there is a quote from jill banfield
where she says that
there could be genome editing tools long
term but it's really too early to
speculate
exactly what they might be at this time
but no doubt
there is huge potential for new
information new biochemistry
what a sentence but it's also worth
mentioning that jill works in close
proximity with jennifer doudna and in
fact she tweeted that later this year
she will again sit across the table from
jennifer and we will talk about how we
might begin to explore the technological
and environmental importance of this
discovery
so i think what i like most about this
preprint is that it's a nice reminder of
the fact that there's just so much
fascinating biology out there in the
world
like i mean us humans are pretty cool
and clever but we can't make weird
polymers like plants
or fly or see in the dark or communicate
through vibrations underground
or oxidize methane and so kind of
fitting with the potential for the use
of
borgs in mitigating climate change it
reinforces the point of
being able to preserve the ecosystem
that is off as there's so much biology
out there that we still don't fully
understand
and also makes me think of the kind of
just crazy biology out there
and to quote jurassic park lifer
finds a way and that's what i think is
always important to remember
so yeah moral of the video biology is
awesome
so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video i mean how could
you not like this is completely novel
stuff
go read the preprint and jill's great
twitter thread
and let me know your thoughts in the
comments also please educate me further
on the borg reference
i'm more jurassic park than star trek
clearly
anyway thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening